[Music]
stone is the foundation of hawaii
we use stone
to make our food
[Music]
and we use it in battle
this method of traditional stone carving
cannot be forgotten
i am the last stone carver that carved
these stones from hawaii
[Music]
i've been carving stone
for 40 years
[Music]
i can carve from a small one pound stone
to four tons using
neolithic methods which is so essential
in hawaiian people's lives
to do the carvings i've managed to
replicate stone tools that were used
by my ancestors
it requires you to have endurance
it requires you to have
patience
once a piece breaks off it's not the
same it's either you give it your best
or you don't do it at all
before i go about picking up the stone i
do a prayer i pray before i take
[Music]
when you're down at the ocean you notice
all different sizes and shapes that's
called kaha
is a scarring of stone from water water
cuts the pathways of these gulches and
rivers
and shapes the stones
into
what you see when it's down at the beach
there are days when i don't find any
stone
i'll be walking all day but it tells me
it's not time
it finds me
as i
look at it and i touch it
it reveals to me what it's going to be
shaped into
it's annoying
it's so strong that i just can't walk
away from it
this rock
i know
will make a great poi pounder
i will pick it up bring it home and
start the process of chipping and
grinding stone on stone
it's
countless
strikes
in order to bring about what's inside
if you force yourself upon it it will
resist
i hear and i start to feel the direction
it wants to go in
and you realize it's not
you who shape the stone it's the stone
who shapes you
after completing it you feel good that
you have been able to take something so
large and shape it to bring about a form
that will
give life
[Music]
the smaller stone taught me how to do
the big stone one of the most important
pieces for me is situated in an ancient
burial ground
at the western end of maui
the stone sculpture has a story
there are two figures one coming down
and one going up
and there's a hole on the top of the
sculpture which is a portal it's the
cycle of life
when i am gone that story in the stone
will live on because stones
are forever
[Music]
you